hey Vsauce it's Michael and of course
Lucy and we have some really great news
for you I've been playing Starcraft 2 a
lot the past few days I've actually been
playing The Lost Viking more than the
actual game I mean that's worth $60
right speaking of games that just came
out recently I've also been playing a
lot of gta4 and I started thinking what
if we combined the two games GTA 4
Starcraft 2 sounds perfect right hello
Nico it looks like you're busy but go
bowling with me I want to go bowling
it's the least fun part of the game stop
what you're doing and go bowling with me
let's bowled if you don't do it I'm
gonna hate you okay yeah that would
totally suck Wow um well okay here's
something that doesn't suck in fact it's
the opposite of suck it blows um it's
just a it's just a good thing I've got
two pieces of exciting news first of all
I just bought a brand new character for
up all night
it cost a dollar fifty because up all
night is high budget entertainment
secondly if you don't already have
Starcraft 2 but you'd really like to
play I'm giving away both of my guest
passes to commenters below so leave a
comment any kind you want for the entire
weekend comment as often as you want and
on Tuesday at noon Eastern I will
release both of these codes to two
different people you'll get 7 hours of
gameplay or 14 days whichever happens
first so good luck happy commenting and
have a great weekend Lucy say bye she's
a jerk
say you got a real pretty mouth oh my
cousin Lester saw a zergling once